welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman today and don't forget you can
follow me on twitter in fact on all
social media at farren balanced you can
also get me on youtube.com
fair and balanced and the big youtube
channel youtube.com slash the ring of
fire
well folks we've done a good job today
so far of not
talking about donald trump
so let's talk about donald trump right
now because there has been some some
trump developments this week uh the
first thing i want to talk about here
there was a piece this week from a good
friend of mine at salon.com writer by
the name of chauncey de vega
a piece titled are trump's followers
being conned
no
they gave him 100 million because they
love him
if you have a chance i encourage
everybody go read this piece because i
love it
see for a long time
many many years actually
i have been saying that trump is conning
his supporters
so when i saw this piece i almost felt
like oh oh no i hope i'm not mentioned
in it because i've had mentioned they'd
be were being conned even earlier this
week when it was reported that donald
trump had a hundred million dollars
a hundred million dollars that he is
definitely not using to help his good
friend rudy giuliani but that's a story
for a different day that david actually
covered earlier this week
either way trump's got a hundred million
dollars
he's raising it from all over the
country people just sending him money
money money
he's spending it at his own properties
to a degree hundreds of thousands of
dollars have been spent on his own
properties which he has a hundred
percent interest in some of the
properties where it's been spent so most
of it goes right back into his own
pocket
so
my logical conclusion is yes these
individuals are being conned because
some of this money a good chunk of it
was raised under the guise of we're
going to use this the trump pacs were
going to use this
to pay for ballot audits to pay for
election challenges
and they spent a whopping zero dollars
on it
so they gave trump money
thinking it was going to one thing and
then it didn't go to that
and i you know would come to the
conclusion logically
these people are being conned
but chauncey de vega actually makes a
much better point
than i was able to make
and he says
it's not that they're being conned
sure they might be being conned but they
also don't care they would still give
the money to him regardless
and there's a great explanation as to
why
see we found out late last year
that the trump campaign was essentially
and the rnc did it i think a little bit
too but anyway they were essentially
scamming their supporters and auto
enrolling them in these monthly
donations
so somebody thought they're giving a
one-time donation they didn't read the
fine print they didn't go through all
the you know hurdles
to turn off the recurring payment
and so they just kept month after month
after month some people lost you know
tons and tons of money for this
and even after they turned it off though
some of them are still giving money to
donald trump
they said oh yeah it was horrible we got
swindled here
i was thinking of giving money
and that's just one
example that you know kind of proves the
point that
they don't care that they're being
conned
and that's a point that the vega really
makes very well in this piece is that
even if the money doesn't go
where they think it's going to go
even if they're told one thing and a
completely opposite thing happens
they still like him
they still want him to be the president
they still support him they are still
going to give him
that money
now i had actually mentioned in a
segment on my channel fair balance
earlier this week
that i've run out of sympathy for these
people i have no more empathy
if they go bankrupt giving money to
donald trump
sure i don't want it to happen but at
this point they've had enough warnings
that if it happens it happens
because
it's worse than being conned
and that's kind of the point that the
vega makes in the piece you know that
that's that's the big
conclusion here is that it's worse than
a con
it's a cult
that's what it is it doesn't matter what
he does to some of these people
again i'm not saying all republicans are
in the cult but you do have this
die-hard sect of trump supporters that
it is really difficult to describe them
as anything else because it doesn't
matter what he says it doesn't matter
what he does it doesn't matter if he
lies to their face about it heck we got
reports that he likely didn't donate the
last couple
months of his salary like he promised to
always do and his kids would always
boast about on social media
we also know that gdp growth under
donald trump this another story came out
this week
was the lowest it's ever been since the
great depression
no president had worse gdp growth than
donald trump george w bush came close
his was 1.8 percent over eight years
trump's was 1.6 over four years so
economically speaking the guy was really
really bad
but the supporters don't care
they're still clamoring for him they
still want more from him they still want
him to be president again
probably holding out hope that what is
this a week from august 13th at this
point oh my god
you know if lindell's original
correction was correct or prediction was
correct excuse me we'd be a week away
from trump coming back and these people
would love it they don't care about the
lies they don't care about the vulgar
behavior they don't care about how he
mocked a disabled reporter way back in
the day they don't care about any of it
and they don't care what he uses their
money for
they just want to keep giving it to him
and at this point those individuals
it's likely that they can't be pulled
out of this certainly not by somebody
like me
you know you would need somebody who
actually understands that kind of cult
mentality and how to actually deprogram
people
which yes there are experts in that
and those are the ones who really would
have to work on these individuals
but until then they're going to keep
giving until they can't give any more
they know they're being conned
they just stopped caring